[Applause]
[Music]
i was just speaking over the clip and
saying how beautiful you looked head to
toe so do you oh thank you and i'm not
wearing a ton of color today i wore
enough color for the both of us okay
good and everybody here is bringing it
with the color yeah literally everybody
has color on i love it color it changes
everything you don't like something you
change the color you love it it's just
weird and color is very mood inducing i
feel like i wear a lot of red for danger
just no danger is coming when i'm coming
and hot yeah and bright it apparently
attracts men
well cheryl wants nothing to do with
that apparently not actually girl
doesn't want to attract a new man so
maybe red isn't her color anymore but
say for her not wanting to attract men
you've made a big difference with your
character in a lot of people's lives
yeah thank you um i actually called the
showrunner and joined the pilot and said
i think cheryl's a lesbian she doesn't
like men and he was like great let's
unpack that let's talk about it and
sure enough we had her come out in
season two and i think that's the
coolest thing i've gotten to do as an
actor so far is have my art touch
somebody's life like that i've had a
couple of fans come up and say that it's
been a huge inspiration to them to come
out which has been incredible well i
think your show definitely uh has major
ages
attending the party
but i'm sure there's also a lot of young
people watching it who are at a tender
age yeah and let's face it growing up is
a very
beautiful uncomfortable raw
funny uh awkward awkward journey thing
yeah so if people can see
that that's out there then maybe it
makes them feel more welcome may i ask
why you had that instinct to do that
i don't know how to explain it i just
knew in my gut she had to kiss a guy
in season one and if that was the
confirmation for me it was like she's
for sure not into men
i applaud you for ingratiating that into
your character and into the show because
i'm sure it really speaks to some of the
audience
who might not be being spoken to
otherwise and good for the show for
listening to you yeah well it's great
because we're on a show where there's
like a very open dialogue between the
show runner and ourselves and the
costume designers and everybody it's
very collaborative
but i think we're trying to create a
show at least to the best of our ability
that is representative of what the world
looks like and i think that when we
started the show seeing a lesbian
relationship on tv was kind of rare i
mean the l word obviously praised but i
mean that was fairly rare for a teen
show so for us to do that it was really
exciting and new and now i feel like i'm
seeing it more which is fantastic that
representation is important i love your
co-worker too cole sprouse he came on
the show did he think the world of him
and his photography
he's amazing he's amazing and funny and
cool charming it's so annoying he's kind
of the complete pack it's so annoying i
know and talented and has a twin brother
which is actually better to be honest
yeah when you're mad at cool you hang
out with dylan it's great double down on
their awesomeness exactly um well season
six of riverdale premieres tonight um
there have been storylines about organ
harvesting uh cults serial killers so
i'm intrigued what's next sacrifice
interesting blood uh-huh more blood than
you've ever seen uh-huh sacrifice like
you i don't that's lovely um
there was a deer there's another
sacrifice coming up soon that's exciting
um well you have two new projects about
i am so excited for you to tell me about
them there's jane
and there's also about fate yes so will
you tell me about them both jane is
really precious to me i produced it's
the first project i produced from the
ground up congratulations
um
congratulations
um do you have a production company it
is in the works right now it's very
exciting for me so i'm looking for a new
option to material or material option do
you have a name for it do you have i do
i haven't announced it i'm still working
on it all right
when i do i'll come back and we can talk
about it um but jane is really important
to me because i struggle with anxiety
and panic attacks a lot it's something
that i've dealt with for a long time and
even more so when the show came out
obviously it's just what the nature of
our industry is um and so when i read
the script i felt like it personified
anxiety so well to me that i spoke to me
in a way i'd never read or seen anything
before that did that it made me feel
seen which is what i make art for right
so when i read that i was like i have to
make this and it didn't have financing
so we worked to make it happen and it
was a bootleg and it worked and i'm
really excited for that to come out i
just finished my final cut of it oh i
can't wait to see it
can you tell me about your other project
please yes about fate is a really fun
romantic comedy with emma roberts where
i play the lead thomas mann's girlfriend
she's fun and kooky and a little crazy
in the best way and very career driven
and uh doesn't get what she wants and
doesn't like that and she's pretty
manipulative which is fun she sounds
like cheryl when i describe her to be
honest but she's nothing like cheryl
she's super fun and different and her
name is clementine oh i love that name
and it's fun to be like manipulative and
all these things that you wouldn't be in
real life 100
like i would never manipulate people
i've always wanted to play like a black
widow character because i'm so not a
black widow
well 23 million followers on instagram
and um
[Applause]
it's a big deal social media is our new
frontier i imagine what parents thought
when they rolled in those radios and tvs
and then you've got the internet and
this is the new frontier we all have
platforms and abilities to you know have
a voice or show and share
so you posted a video actually um last
year um and it's a cute holiday video
and so because it's the holidays i
thought maybe if it's okay can we share
it sure yeah okay roll the tape
this is
[Music]
we
[Music]
[Applause]
definitely before social media that was
kicking it old school like the time
count in there yep i love it thank you
for sharing that it's so sweet to see
you in many different iterations
characters ages all of it but it is so
wonderful to have this conversation with
you thank you for coming here thanks for
having me
[Applause]
season six of riverdale returns tonight
on the cw at 9 00 eastern and eight
o'clock central we'll all be on the
feeder
[Music]